we're old how old are you guys we're
we're all old old let's not even talk
about it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's hang on for a second Bryce is 23.
that's insane what is what's wrong with
that people are people are born after we
were how old are you guys
how old is 42. no how old do you think I
think I think I think Cody's like close
to my age
oh no 25
oh no he just pointed right only at him
though what about wait what about Noah I
will take that 35 just kidding I'm just
kidding how old do you think I am like
26. oh I love you dude [ __ ] my man
wasn't actually on my man how old are
you guys you guys are making anything
like that that's what he said shut the
[ __ ] up shut up you shut your [ __ ]
mouth
we found one of his insecurities
are you crazy
no I'm 31 man I'm 31. yeah same
all these faces
he was like he was like oh damn these
[ __ ] Lane
no I literally didn't even want to look
at his face when he said that he's the
one sitting there with a dick coming out
of the back of his head and he's like
yeah wait because they're lame as [ __ ]
wait is Dick's coming out
I mean I mean that metaphorically like
in his like spiritual way yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's of course
yeah exactly yeah um
I didn't even want to see his reaction I
looked directly at you because I wanted
to Shield myself from I can't even look
at him he's 23. I know man that's
[ __ ] dude yeah that's why you're out
there you go gym because that's the only
thing that matters yeah yeah nothing
else going on it matters at that age
just gym gym what do you do in your
spare time Bryce I'm honestly I'm like
shooting a lot of movies are you
actually you said that earlier but you
actually yeah like I was making a joke
but also like not really so sick to be
23 and just like oh I'm shooting a ton
of movies yeah plural too like yeah like
obviously the boxing career wasn't like
for me
I think so they're like yo you're kind
of good at like acting like go for it
are you saying did he lose did you lose
a boxing fight it was [ __ ] up what was
that did you guys
I got thrown on the ground oh yeah but I
was I was getting my ass kicked don't
get me wrong okay
uh Austin McBroom so what the [ __ ] you
didn't know is this bro I don't [ __ ]
no I need this [ __ ] dude I do politics
like I've recently got a tick tock like
I don't even look at it usually I
literally okay you want to know how old
I am I look at Tick Tock and I'm like
this is market research because I'm like
this is a social media platform that's
like exploding right like it's like the
oldest conversation I've heard of my
entire life
yeah market research my kids are really
into it
but straight up like I'm not even there
because like I'm not there
enthusiastically like I'm there because
I'm like I have to I'm an influencer and
it's just all you
well on Tech talk just clips of you
really at least that's my algorithm it's
funny that you guys said about your uh
for you page what's your for you page
now it's kind of like training videos
honestly my I've been on Tick Tock once
in the past like three months my
algorithm changes every week well I just
have to say I opened Tick Tock last
night for just a few minutes in like the
third video I saw was a shirtless man
massaging a raw chicken
so what does that say about you I just I
like I like to cook yeah I just like
weird you're supposed to be Russian
chicken before oh yeah yeah like he's
just sitting there like just trying to
be funny just yeah wait this is my
algorithm hold on I gotta send it keep
talking because well now you got us like
ready well I know well I mean I'll try
I'll say my piece on on Tick Tock
algorithm first of all it knows you
better than you know yourself yeah I
think that's been that's cliche at this
point everybody knows that but okay
having said that I throw curveballs
because like you I look at weird [ __ ] on
Tick Tock like my favorite type of tick
tocks is like people living in like
[ __ ] communes and like yeah Arkansas
okay uh is the correct pronunciation
don't correct me on that and and they're
like they literally like yeah 87 000 IRS
agents are coming to my house dude I'm
gonna [ __ ] I want to see this yeah and
they're like I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot
all of them right like so I look at guys
like that and it's like one like you
know what I mean yeah so it it my
algorithm was so busted for the longest
time because like I also look at like
hot girls so then Tick Tock found the
intersection of that which was hot girls
hot Arkansas girls
no no straight up only fans girls that
were like trying to promote their only
fans by doing like um
by doing like duck hunting but duck
hunting themed only fans what like
country girls like riding a [ __ ]
track they're naked like oh look yeah
what do you mean hot lady dippers
what do you mean you don't need the hot
word
oh that's like okay it's just lighting
yeah okay but yeah no they were like
like this girl be on like a [ __ ] like
expensive piece of machinery and she's
like I'm riding this today like on my
intriguez
yeah no I wish I saved it bro it was so
good like because it nailed me I was
like damn she's in real tree she's like
going fishing and she's like you know a
real treat Hassan we have to get you
outside dude we have to get you outside
bro I I go outside sometimes yeah I
don't believe it I think [ __ ] Camp is
the most outside you've been in 12
months it was [ __ ] great actually
yeah but hold up I I want you guys to
see this because this [ __ ] killed like
six million likes holy [ __ ] I know
that's a light day in office for you
though right Bryce huh that's a light
day in the office he's like yeah I did
that on a bicycle yeah
bro
look at how many bubbles are in there
dude
does he have a beard or is that a tattoo
it's a tattoo yeah it's like a mom yo
that's awesome he's a beard tattoo
he's he's really trying to get into this
oh something's wrong
bobas I think yeah normally he goes for
the big boys yeah they put the small
he's pissed they put the little guys in
there
bro that's way too many Boba this is
that feeling when you when you've been
having like a really shitty day and
you're like looking forward to one
specific thing yeah
you're looking forward to your big
confused with the comments
just wait is that what it is is it tiny
bobas that's why he's pissed I think he
wants to suck down the big boys he wants
the big ones I mean who doesn't yeah
what
now watch this though you've never had a
big juicy boba oh it's gonna blow up on
them
he's got it in
he's like well maybe it's you know maybe
they're still good
hmm
okay yeah it's not doing it
pretty upset I would be too only one
thing to do at this point yeah what's he
gonna do what would you do suck down the
boat was man I I'd finish that [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ]
oh dude
oh
bro wondering I was like why does this
have 4.6 million likes this has to be a
crazy video yeah this [ __ ] snorts
Boba I like I like that I thought it was
so funny even without the snorting yeah
how frustrated he is over this something
so stupid I I can't get over how many
bobas was in there
funny part there's a bit of inside joke
but Cody will sit through that but he
won't watch a [ __ ] movie on a
television this [ __ ] will sit
this fool will not watch a movie if I
put a gun to his head bro that's why he
thought he was 25 by the way yeah like
that's it yeah we got to be more Zoomer
like dude yeah yeah oh man
that was too long
I just laughed at you why are you
[ __ ] laughing because you called him
Zoomer he is a Zoomer yeah but he's is
he not I don't even know anymore but he
doesn't he he's like what are you
talking about yeah well I mean don't you
drink Jim and girls
I don't [ __ ] I don't know well hold
up
uh I'm okay so you never saw Bryce's
fight no I watched Gibb I don't even
know anything about like the the broom
guy I don't even know anything I just
don't know anything about Austin McBroom
no I just know like he's the dude with
the kids that's the Family Guy right
yeah yeah
um and he like he's like kind of a
grifter right that's what I know like I
know he's like he's like shady so
basically him and Bryce fought Bryce
really sold it Bryce was like I've been
in 40 street fights like I was I was
dude I was memeing the whole thing but
like also just wait just also just
saying everything to get everyone to
watch you couldn't beat that dude's ass
no dude like I'm gonna be honest I was
nervous I was like no Austin is a walk
outside 30 000 people like are in the
audience booing me I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
but Austin's an athlete yeah he's
actually an athlete like he's actually
very it's a very challenging fight no
but the worst part was he got beat and
then you didn't get paid I was about to
say yeah did he can you talk about it um
yeah I mean we're in like legal things
but uh I mean there's definitely been
some payment oh that's good yeah but not
the full thing not the full promised
amount damn and it's been how long
um a year over a year he beat your ass
and he didn't pay you right yeah but hey
if you look at his last fight he got ten
thousand dollars first to get knocked
out five times yeah and then I thought
it was seven it was it was five times
ten thousand dollars and 200 people
bought tickets to the event yeah she
gave away a thousand and then
pay-per-view I'm guessing seven people
yeah everyone else a legally dude it was
one guy who restreamed it to everyone
else yeah yeah I see like there's no I
was the one guy who paid for it oh
you're a big you're a big uh oh yeah no
no I believe
you were shocked I was shocked he got
dropped that many times no I mean I knew
that fight wasn't gonna sell because
like what no one was entertaining on the
card really but big Giver it's like
don't shrug give bro I mean I mean like
but he's he's good in the UK
If it was the UK he would have sold out
no you're right you're right sorry you
just mean like in terms of selling here
yeah in the U.S like for the stadium who
is The Giver uh the Nissan Gib what damn
you sound old as hell bro I don't need
to get you off twitch what are you
talking about bro I don't really know
either honestly it's a young I don't
know Gibb other than the fights with
Jake yeah
the big Giver you said seven figure out
seven figure Giver how big what do you
mean like what how big is the giver yeah
oh he's he's not bigger than you like if
if we're talking about gibbers you're
the biggest Giver okay good okay I like
to maintain that position yeah but give
is just big Gib